cette norme les chroniques de la haine
ordinaire
[Musique]
par un papa paroisse
à
[Musique]
résumé du chapitre précédent
année alexandre profite du mois de juin
pour ne pas partir en août
il grande dans leur maison au bord d'une
plage atlantique avec leurs deux enfants
probablement des petites filles je peux
bien suivi le début
soudain alors qu'alexandre sur la
terrasse face au couchant fait rien qu'à
se poser des questions fondamentales de
type romantique de bains ain s'écrit
tabac vu les filles c'est bien ce que
visait ces défis
non il n'a pas vu les filles tous les
étés ils perdent les filles
10 20 fois la maison le jardin la plage
sont vastes et les enfants en sortir du
bas âge puissamment volatiles
pessimiste sans nuance 10 20 fois il
nourrit goulûment son angoisse maladive
de ses escapades dont il entrevoit
toujours l'issue la plus tragique
ma fille ma petite ma porcelaine
toujours je t'imagine brisé du jour où
ses enfants sont nés cet homme n'a cessé
au creux de ses nuits blanches et de
séjour noir de les entrevoir courant nu
sous les bombes éclatent et sous des
camions 10 très torturée jusqu'au choeur
par les fureurs immonde dit réfutable
monstres ou rouler sur les vagues
apprend les algues mortes en suppliant
des yeux pour rattraper la vie au lieu
de me reproduire j'aurais dû acheter des
poissons rouges soupire tire
avec une minutie de flics obtus il se
met à fouiller contre fouillé le garage
la voiture l'aed fusain la maison pièce
à pièce où ils purent leurs deux noms
pendant qu insidieusement le froid blanc
d'une horreurs innommables lui montent
aux tripes étouffant peu à peu l'autre
lui-même qui s'épuise à trouver que tout
va bien les gars rien à dire c'est tout
bon pour un bon match est un bon match
au bout de vingt minutes on sort la
voiture le vélo les voisins la police et
les chiens je suis formel ans n'a rien
vu sur l'eau affirme le pimpant crs
balnéaire sur l'eau je m'en fous mais
sous l'eau
risque-t-il exhibant sans vergogne son
humour clé en main avec vue imprenable
sur le cimetière
c'est plus fort que lui plus la
situation est sombre plus ils en rient
juifs aux années sombres il aurait sans
doute contre péter aux portes des
chambres à gaz n'eussent été les menaces
du fouet il horreur qu'on le fait de
noter qu'entre pète
ces petites ne se sont pas noyés c'est
donc un coût du syndic des plages
encore qu'en si peu de code sexualité de
groupe chez les assassins pédophiles
il pense à solder sa planche à voile et
le magnétoscope portable pour réunir le
montant de la rançon peut-être
faudra-t-il aussi songer à vendre la
maison la collection de tire bouchon et
les bords de 75 qu'il ne comptait pas
ouvrir avant le printemps 89 ou pas
après non plus à cause de la
chimiothérapie
parce que bien sûr il attend son cancer
incessamment mais de toute façon
de toute façon dès les premiers
symptômes il finira sa cave à la
carabine
après l'heure du chien après l'heure du
loup on a toujours rien trouvé la mère
est folle est toute blanche elle tord
ses doigts et ses yeux souvent d'où
dessine dans ceux d'alexandre la même
horreur sans mesure où ils vont sombrer
c'est sûr
pourquoi l'idée que ses enfants souffre
lui est elle si complètement
insupportable alors qu'il dort dîne et b
en paix quand ceux des autres s'écrase
en autocar ce club soda palme ou crève
de faim sur le sein flapi d'une négresse
efflanqué
oms a endormi dit la plus petite et bt
qu'un voisin découvre à la nuit assise
au milieu du jardin échevelé bouffi
torpeur ronronnante elle avait joué au
sous marin noir dans le grand placard de
leur chambre saturé d'air du large et de
soleil lourd elle avait succombé au
sommeil sur un tapis roulé de l'autre
côté de la porte close mais où étiez
vous hurle le père dans un crime
métallique de colère brisé où étiez-vous
suffoque la mer vacillante sur la
violence intolérable du soulagement qui
la submerge comme un scaphandrier
d'apocalypse trop brutalement remontée
des enfers
on s'est endormi on s'est endormi
rectifie t-il un dixième de seconde
avant de concevoir à silencieusement
l'ampleur l'incongruité et la sottise
pédagogique de sa remarque c'est
congénitale il a toujours eu un respect
profond presque craintifs pour la langue
la grammaire la syntaxe vocabulaire et
toutes ces conneries à la maternelle
déjà il ne disait plus qu'à kaboul dans
la maîtresse un maillot de bain
mais la chair est triste hélas et j'ai
lu tous les livres
papa oms a fait violer on s'est fait
violer
enfin bon elle savait endormie elle
savait réveiller et les voici qui
torture en payant des langoustines
défunte qu'est les cartels pour
s'engager sous la lune que la mère
endormie réfléchir intensément
au secours docteur je ressens comme un
point là c'est un bonheur insupportable
au rebond
jusqu'où ça anglure à la mièvrerie
lellouche yens de ce feuilleton sirupeux
à la gloire de la famille française
c'est ce que vous saurez en écoutant la
suite demain à la même heure sur cette
même chaîne à moins que je change d'avis
d'ici là ce qui pourrait bien arriver
car je fais exactement ce que je veux
sur france inter
je peux même dire zigounette mêmes
chirac poil aux pattes
alors qu'à radio chili on a tout juste
le droit de dire général ce qui est
accro
quant à ces féroces soldats je le dis
c'est pas pour capter mais ils font rien
qu'à mûrir dans nos campagnes
[Musique]
etonnant non